What do you get when you combine parts from
an old battery pack with some common household
ingredients? Mix them together and you get
these .. A batch of super cheap, and easy
to make, smoke flares.
Most hardware stores have recycling bins for
disposing of old batteries. That's where I
got this one for free. I'm going to start
by removing the screws, and these ones require
a torx bit, so once I've found the right size,
the 6 screws get removed and then with a little
wiggle, the top assembly pulls right out.
With that removed I've got access to the 15
cells that make up the battery pack, and I'm
gonna need to get them apart. So the tape
comes off and the connector bands are all
removed so that I'm left with a total of 15
sub C Ni-Cd batteries. They're just over 1
volt each and some of them are still good,
but it's actually the casing that I'm after.
The battery easily pushes out now, leaving
me with a clean casing that should work great
for the body of my smoke flare. It even has
a flat bottom that will come in handy later
on. Ok, all the batteries are shelled, and
I'm gonna use some cardboard for the next
step, but before I do, I'll pack these batteries
back into the casing, and send them back for
recycling. Alright, to finish these casings,
I'll add a bead of hot glue to the flat part
on the bottoms, and press them down on the
cardboard to cool down. That gets repeated
with all the other casings, and I'm leaving
a bit of a gap because these will need to
be cut individually later on. Now it's time
to make the composition that will give us
our smokey flare. I'm using 60% KNO3 stump
remover and 40% table sugar, being very careful
to not mix them too much. This is poured very
gently into a pan set on medium heat, and
I've made about 400 grams of the composition
in hopes that it will fill all the containers.
After a few minutes, I'll begin to fold the
mixture into itself because you can see the
sugar on the bottom is beginning to caramelize.
I'll continue folding in gently until the
mixture has melted and absorbed all the white
powder, and at this point it should be runny
enough to pour into the casings. Ok I've readied
this casing, as well as a piece of home made
fuse cord that I made in a different project.
Using a small spatula, the liquid is poured
into the casing, and the edge of the pan wiped
clean to prevent too much dripping. The last
step is to add the fuse, making sure to push
it all the way to the bottom, and now we can
let this cool until it hardens. The same thing
is done with all the others, and when they're
cooled and cut apart, the batch is complete.
This is a fairly slow burning fuse and will
give me plenty of time to get away, so when
it's lit I'll watch from a distance to see
if our smoke fountain will work. Alright it
looks like it is working, and now here comes
the smoke. For it's size it actually puts
off quite a bit of smoke, burning for around
15 seconds, until all the fuel is used up.
The casing is completely toasted as well,
but the cardboard base is intact, and its
prevented the concrete from getting any scorch
marks. Here goes another one, and you probably
noticed I'm doing this outside in an open
area. That's because there's plenty of ventilation
for when the smoke starts to get thick. You
don't want these going off in a confined area
because you can see how a thick smoke could
build and linger. Just for fun, I tried making
another batch with a 60% ratio of sugar to
see if it would burn slower. Unfortunately
it burned so slow it was painful to watch.
There was some smoke, but all in all, it kind
of looked more like one of those black snake
fireworks instead. Next I tried making a batch
where the ingredients were mixed together
extremely well, and experimented with various
home-made fuses. I even tried adding saw-dust
to see what that would do. Well it wasn't
a good idea. I think the sawdust added air
pockets that made them go completely ballistic.
These were more like unguided rockets than
anything, because they burned so fast I couldn't
get them to stay still. So remember, to get
a nice balanced burn with plenty of smoke
like this, it's important that you have the
right ingredients, the right ratios, and the
right mix. Every batch is a little different,
so be careful and be safe. Well there's the
technique I used for some cheap home-made
smoke flares. If you liked this project, perhaps
you'll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com